It makes the brain feel as if time has passed about one percent its normal speed.
If we play this right, we could take the whole city.
800 million people living in the ruin of the old world.
Only one thing fighting for order in the chaos.
The men and women of the Hall of Justice.
Peach Trees is the manufacturing base for all of the Slo-Mo in Mega City One.
You know how often we get a judge up in Peach Trees?
Well, you got one now.
She has control of everything.
Levels one to 200.
This is Ma-Ma. Somewhere in this block are two judges.
That's not good.
I want them dead.
We're gonna have to go through them.
Rookie, you ready?
Yeah.
You look ready.
Fire!
Judgment time.
Let's finish this.
Ma-Ma is not the law.
I'm the law.
Negotiation is over.
The sentence is death.